what muscles do I use when I take a
free-throw excellent question LeBron so
you could imagine whenever you do
anything whenever you stand or even run
you're using a ton of muscles just to
keep your balance just to keep your body
rigid but what we're gonna focus on are
the muscles in particular that are
directly acting on the ball to make the
ball go in that direction to make it
accelerate upwards and towards the
basket which you would hopefully do when
you are taking a free-throw so the
muscles that are doing that are the ones
that help your fingers go help your
fingers go in that direction help the
palm of your hand go in that direction
and help your entire forearm your entire
forearm to go in that direction and
obviously there's a ton of other muscles
at work even the muscles that keep your
entire arm above your head like this the
muscles that keep you standing but we're
just gonna focus on these muscles right
over here
so first the muscles that make you allow
your fingers to go in the direction of
the that you want the ball to go in and
your palm and you might be surprised to
find that most of those muscles actually
do not sit in the hand those muscles
actually sit in the forearm those
muscles are actually here so the muscles
in the front of your forearm right here
they're actually all about they're all
about flexing the fingers and the hands
in that direction and we've diagrammed
them here and there's a bunch of names
for them and I encourage folks to look
them up but it's a really interesting
thing because we're often used to
muscles being directly where the motion
is but in this case these muscles when
they're in action they contract they
contract and muscles when they're in
action do contract so they're going to
contract and they're going to pull
essentially on tendons they're gonna
pull the whole hand that way you could
view it as a kind of a pulley so if this
was if you view your wrist joint as kind
of a as a as a pulley of some kind and
then if you had a rope if you had a rope
that is attached let's say it's attached
to another block and that block you can
kind of view as your hand and your
fingers so that block is your hand these
muscles these muscles right over here
they contract this way so it's analogous
to pulling on this rope and if you were
to pull on this rope
what would happen to this block up here
well this block up here is going to go
in that general direction so that's what
keeps your hand and your fingers going
that way but what about the entire
forearm so once again the muscles that
get your entire forearm going in that
direction aren't in your forearm they
are in the back of your upper arm so
they are right over here often referred
to as the triceps the official name are
the triceps brachii
but they're right over here and it's
called triceps because it's kind of a
three-headed muscle there's three muscle
bundles that are going on and when these
muscles right over here your triceps
when they contract when they contract
they allow your entire forearm to
essentially straighten out on your elbow
so they'll go in that direction in this
case when this this muscle the triceps
contract your entire forearm is going to
pivot on your elbow and go and go like
that which will allow the basket to go
in the intended direction